well today at the hustings in perth in
central scotland liz truss and mauricio
sunak have attacked the snp and its
demands for a new referendum as well as
the party's record while in power in
scotland let's talk to the columnist at
the daily telegraph alan cochran and
columnist for the herald and the
national leslie riddick great to see you
both this evening thank you very much i
know you're watching uh the hustings
with interest i'll i'll stop i'll ask
you both the same question actually alan
why don't you kick things off who do you
think came out on top tonight
well i think from the reaction of the
crowd the delegates there was about a
thousand there i think liz trust
got through them better and
that just probably means that they've
already voted for her i thought soon it
was uh richard sooner was very
impressive on several issues especially
he was more committed on the on what he
would do about the energy questions um i
don't think there was much in it but
i just think that given the reaction
from the delegates the re the tory
members
it seems that
the the polls are right and trust has
got it at home and host so liz trust
perhaps had the edge tonight is that
something you would agree with leslie
yes i would say that that she certainly
worked the room and got the responses
and got the emotional connection going
about the union i've got to say somebody
who is an independent supporter watching
this um it's so otherworldly to watch
this kind of debate because it's within
shades of grey
in a very large palette in scotland that
generally speaking does not vote
conservative i mean just tediously to
put the facts into it there are 44 snp
mps and six tory mps so we're hyper
concentrating on that spectrum obviously
because the winner will form the next
we'll provide the next prime minister
but it's a it's a strange thing to watch
as many of the questions and answers
suggested that not only was there
obviously opposition to independence but
even to the current devolved settlement
which the vast majority of scots back
so leslie on that point
is there a sense in scotland that the
two leadership candidates really have
ignored scotland up until and up until
this point do you know it's not even
that i know everybody likes to play this
personality card there was no cameron
bounce for david cameron there was no
main magic for theresa may john major
made bullish remarks and then lost every
single tory mp in 1997. scots don't vote
conservative in the main that's it so
you know our recent uh some opinion
polls out today suggest that there might
be a move of 25 or 15 to 20 percent if
either candidate when either candidate
becomes uh the tory leader or next prime
minister so
in a sense this feels a little academic
watching it and it's not really a very
balanced debate because we only have
that very small shade of opinion arguing
with itself
yeah i was very interested in that poll
wasn't it um
and alan that's the point uh isn't it
that actually when it comes to scotland
and to scottish issues there isn't
really a great deal between these two
candidates that they agree on quite a
lot
here's me being trying to keep off
political uh opinion and try and do a
neutral verdict on tonight's um
event until i heard leslie i'll forget
about my neutrality for a minute it is
it is about
the daft issue of independence and this
sumac's got the best year of the evening
when he he managed to calm the chairman
of the evening's events down by by
saying it
it is balmy to keep going on about
independence when the prime issue in
every household in scotland as in the
whole of the united kingdom is the
energy crisis but if nikola keeps
banging on about
independence
she's quite rightly described as barmy
and by the way anybody who fancies
another referendum just had to look at
the the carry on outside that hall
tonight where everybody who went in
whether journalist or tory was hailed as
tori scum now if that's the sort of
referendum
that
the nationalists want then
it's a good advert for the union i think
well leslie when it comes to another
referendum if liz truss does become
prime minister it doesn't look like it's
going to come any time soon she said
today
i consider myself a child of the union
and to me we're not just neighbors we're
family i will never ever let our family
be split up
yes and is this a strong point i mean
many of us have uh you know have
backgrounds across the whole of the uk
myself included from england northern
ireland wales scotland and that doesn't
stop you having particular views about
the best way to manage society and
there's just this there's this clash of
democratic mandates really however you
want to look at it and it is just the
fact that the scots have voted for a
scottish parliament it has got powers
they keep voting for the snp they've got
mandate after mandate there's no clear
way to square these things i think most
people would concede there's a clash of
mandates now how do you fairly manage
that that's the question we're not
hearing any sort of answer other than
extremely
lofty dismissals of the whole scottish
population's right to some sort of
self-determination and that's annoying
that's the kind of thing that does
become a recruiting sergeant for
independence
but i do think that the issue is
to get back to the issue the issue now
is not independent the poll after paul
and scotland suggest that it's not even
so it's nowhere near the top of issues
for scottish people it's the energy
christian stupid as somebody's bound to
say soon and why not if i was
disappointed with anything and i have
been very disappointed in this the
touring leadership
candidates are just not addressing it in
any detail we've had gordon brown with
nicholas sturgeon over there davey we've
now got kirsten estamos with
precise policies we need that or i would
have thought the country needs that from
the person or the better people who
pretend that they're going to form the
next government i mean risky soon that
did make that point leslie didn't he he
said
and it couldn't be much clearer
independence should not be a priority
right now um let's discuss the cost of
living crisis um and how they uh
approached that this evening what did
you make of what they had to say leslie
well i mean i agree with alan on that
that it's just quite shocking to see how
otherworldly these debates are becoming
when there's a crisis an air of crisis
amongst experts uh on on your station on
on every channel at the moment and you
can end up having non-committal
nonsensical answers actually much of the
time about what would it actually be
done and again we're in a situation
where recent per energy price rises in
france four percent in germany 23
in britain 215
now to come to the point with alan um
and scotland is energy rich that is one
reason why many people would like to see
energy being managed better because it's
currently reserved to westminster so
okay there was no way than anything we
alan i was going to let you have the
final word we've got about 30 seconds
left well
scotland might be energy original but
nicholas doesn't stand off the tap so we
can't have any more oil we can't have
any gas even though the nazi is full of
both
but uh
sorry nicholas says it's our oil and gas
we're the saudi arabia of renewables
we've got a massive future if we could
only exploit it properly and
all right listen plenty to chew over i
appreciate your time this evening thanks
so much alan cochran leslie riddick
thank you both